in a situation hypothetical if you're in
that situation who are you hoping pulls
you out of it or like if someone like if
you come out of that and you look up
you're like oh I feel safe in this like
everything's going to be okay and who do
you put in that same scenario where you
don't feel safe I'm trying to think of
like like like other actors tell I can
tell you mine who Andrew Garfield what
he was [__] Spider-Man yeah dud but
he's he's no muscle tone and he n he was
Spider-Man and the worst Spider-Man
Toby's the worst Spider-Man get the [__]
out of here right now Toby's the worst
Spiderman what are you saying out loud
in public do you need me to say it
louder and slower You So Right Toby
Maguire is the worst Spider-Man so you
go Tom Holland Andrew Garfield Toby oh
my God for I I'm Gonna Give You Tom
Holland this is hard for me because my
I'm I'm walking away from my my my
generation you can't debate Tom Hall I
agree he's funnier than Toby he's the
epitome of that Superhero I agree I
agree I he's the epitome of that
Superhero Stanley even said Tom Holland
was born to play Spider-Man I agree he
didn't say [__] about Toby McGuire yeah
Andrew Garfield was born to play Oliver
from the play Oliver yo him and hacksaw
Ridge though was really good I'm G give
him that uh false what now he might have
been good but hacka Ridge was a bunch of
doooo too oh I disagree you talking
about the dude just running across the
battlefield without a gun yeah I love
that I thought that was a great movie
yeah I'm not and I don't look man Andrew
Garfield is wildly successful and more
successful than I will probably ever be
in my life I just don't think that he's
the I think he's the third best
Spider-Man that being said it's like
saying when I tell you LeBron's second
when you're second all time ever that's
not a knock right so when I say also all
of them are one of three people to play
a it's like the people to play Superman
to play Batman like you're one of a very
few ever yeah it's not a it's like to
say not he's third it's like it's like
criticizing NBA basketball players when
they miss a free throw it's like dude I
would make that dude are you getting
paid $30 million in four years to play
professional basketball no you should
shut up I yeah but so that being said
just judging him against I bet you he
would come in third if they took a
nationwide vote no well I mean he he is
the only Spider-Man to lose lose the
girl I like animated Spider-Man Miles
better than andw is isn't he voiced by
like Jake something uh no he Jake
Johnson played another guy in the new oh
oh okay okay okay you know I think the I
still haven't seen the newest one it's
great uh I hear it's great and I really
want to watch it it's on Netflix so if
you're you're saying you think the
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man movies are
better than the Toby Maguire Spider-Man
movies I didn't say that I didn't say
that at all you think I just said that I
thought Andrew Garfield was a better
Spider-Man than Toby McGuire why he's
not funnier disagree
what what I like the villain I like I
like I like the villains way more and
the storyline and how it all plays out
and I like I just like I like the
earlier Spider-Man the to M I love the
villain the upside down kiss is
Iconic and the Green Goblin is hard to
beat for a super villain he's also just
played so well um but I don't know I
just I I enjoyed watching Garfield on
screen more than I enjoyed watching Toby
when I think of Spider-Man I think of a
kid I think of a I think of a high
school kid I think of a high school kid
who or a college kid who gets bitten
completely by accident on a Toby might
have been 30 when he was playing Toby
looked like he was 40
[Music]
Toby looked like he was 40 when he was
supposed to be 25 yeah he might have
been no dig on Toby again like like
again you are more successful I love his
six sense for paparazzi it makes me
laugh have you seen those videos of Toby
with Paparazzi no but he's been dealing
with Paparazzi I know but nowadays when
to Paparazzi gets around Toby like he
can he doesn't like they'll be behind
him and he can just sense them and
you'll just see in the video him turn
around like this and
go by the way and stare down Paparazzi
there was one where a Paparazzi was like
following him and they tripped over
something or something happened and they
panned it back up to him and he was like
laughing at
them careful there I
[Music]
will his beef with the paparazzi is the
funniest thing do you funny would you go
far so far to say he has a spidey
[Music]
sense oh 100% H the best Spider-Man
second best Spider-Man has a spidey
sense no Andrew Garfield well he's also
had Fame for longer than the other two
why does Andrew Garfield why is he
playing Spider-Man with no muscle tone
that Bo let me tell you something this
is what bothered me about that original
he he's supposed to be like this nerdy
Outcast kid you got bit by a spider and
now you're jacked I don't think that's I
think he just got bit by The Spider and
Matt isn't he jacked a little bit well
but is that what Happ the spider the
spider bites him and he gets muscle no I
think the spider bites him and he get
Toby wakes up the next morning and he's
dink dink dink Tom Holland wakes up the
next morning he's like dink dink dink I
also will say wakes up the next morning
it's like zero muscle tone Johnny but
also didn't he have to build a
Contraption to shoot webs the different
Spider-Man Amazing Spider-Man and the
other Spider-Man one has it built in and
one doesn't I believe that's true also
Matt are you guys talking about comic
accurate yes or movie comic accurate
comic accurate right comic accurate
Garfield's much closer to the comic book
version but uh in the movies getting
bitten by the spider instantly Jacks you
up yes so okay but that's but that's in
the movies comically correct G what
happened to Garfield is more but dude we
here's the problem it's like you know
the first
Aquaman yeah I saw like half it you know
the only problem I had with Amber herd
and I'm gonna go back to um and I put
Andrew Garfield in here I'm putting ree
Witherspoon in the movie Wild and Amber
herd here's the thing if you Amber herd
this was the only problem I had with her
in that movie movie if you are a god a
God you should be muscular who
swims all the
time you have no muscle tone everybody
else around you is [__] jacked at
least put her and you you look like put
her in a buff suit like do something
something so I got a problem with that
it's the same thing Andrew Garfield you
gotta be jacked yo ree Witherspoon did a
movie called wild I loved the book dude
the book was [__] crazy the movie was
so cool I was so excited to see her see
it to to see her do it she's such a
great
actress supposedly she's out on this
Trail for I think 90 days no change in
your muscle tone interesting you you
didn't you didn't want to just put six
weeks in to get your legs a little
jacked or your arms a little jacked so I
believe that you right yeah yeah yeah
this that kind of stuff bothers me man
and you know what it's a continuity
thing look I suspend disbelief all the
time all the time time we all do for
movies but but that's kind of thing
where I'm like what am I looking at I'm
going to suspend my disbelief that these
people can fly and swim underwater but
you're telling me there's no muscle tone
on the gods who swim underwater no take
take that just no no muscle tone on the
gods period end of sentence that's it
like yeah yeah that that because if you
look at any statue or anything depicted
in in mythology in that category they're
all buff they're all extremely gorgeous
but still toned like they're Gods
they're supposed to be the epitome of
what man looks like yeah yeah I'm with
you I'm with you I'm with so no I
understand that McGuire for sure rank
your Spider-Man Spiderman rank your
Spider-Man Andrew at the bottom yeah
Andrew at the bottom yeah yeah he feels
like a bottom he looks like a
[Music]
bottom whoa Andrew Garfield so sorry he
just said that so sorry but come on the
podcast and let's talk about it I don't
think you look like like a b but let's
but come on the podcast let's talk about
it a you almost got me no no no I'm not
I'm not I'm not this is my
shout probably not the best shout but
hey man um and all that being said again
I think he's a wonderful great act I do
too wonderful artist he's done a BN
bunch of good [__] you just happened to
mention the two movies I liked his
movies I also happen to hear nothing but
good things about him I hear he's a
super nice dude by the way and I like
those Spider-Man mov movies you know I
like superheroes [__] I just didn't like
he's still here's the thing also me
bagging on Toby is not that I don't like
Toby and I don't like those Spider-Man
movies again those two dudes are a
specific breed of people who are picked
to be one character that's only been
played by three people yeah ever since
yeah so they're a specific breed and
those movies were still when theing
Marvel Universe it was good yeah Marvel
Universe now cannot wait to watch eeko
canot wait you don't want to watch eeko
are you laughing at Eko you don't want
to watch
Eko let hear it let he tell me tell me
Matt uh so I watched the first episode
and no really I told you I told you H
are you not gonna want finish it
probably not that bad told you I told
you I'm gonna have to watch
it that dude after
endgame for me that was it no dude that
black widow movie was [__] so for me
after endgame was it that those 27 or 30
movies or whatever it was in that
chronological order watching it to go
see endgame in theaters nothing for me
beats that that era of Marvel is
unbeaten have you watched the Hawkeye
show I thought that was doooo stew as
this is a spin-off of that the first 20
minutes of the first episode of EO is
basically just rehashed stuff from
Hawkeye you're definitely not watching
it now Toby Maguire Andrew Garfield go
ahead
what the hell we going to
do